in this video today we will be
showcasing the giant arachnids that have
appeared in movies and tv shows
and we will also include one that was
mentioned in a particular movie but not
seen specifically
these spiders scorpions and arachnid
bugs
are pretty scary and are not meant for
those who have arachnophobia
that is the fear of creepy crawly stuff
so in the end of this video
do comment on which ones are your
favorite and which ones we might have
left
out so here it goes number 10 aragog
seen in the harry potter movie chamber
of secrets aragorp was an acromantula
which was a giant magical species
of spider native to the rainforest of
south east asia particularly borneo
where it inhabited dense jungles they
were believed to be wizard bread
species designed to guard dwellings or
treasure holes
unlike the rest of his species aragorp
had a taste for human flesh and was able
to communicate with humans
via speech in 1993 aragog was described
as the size of a small elephant with a
grey and black hairy body
with milky eyes but in the movie he was
dark coloured with black eyes
and was around five feet tall but with a
leg span of over ten feet
number nine sheila seen in the movie
love the rings the return of the king
shelob is a giant spider and the
daughter of angoliant
mordo was once her homeland and she was
an ally and a rival of
sauron before saron forced her to the
mountains
her brood still infests portions of
mordor and she still wishes to invade
and take back murder from
antique also revenge from sauron she was
encountered by further baggins and
samwise gamji in their quest to destroy
the one ring
as a spawn of angolian shelop would
accurately be classified as a part
spider part demon
though of a spider form in this
adaptation shelop appears as a cgi
animated creature
roughly eight feet in length and
seventeen feet across
number eight tank tang is the secondary
antagonist in the 2002
comedy slash horror film eight legged
freaks
here's a chilean red tarantula who
serves as consuela's second in command
and main henchmen
tang is an enormous tarantula with brown
fur covering his body
excluding certain parts that have fur
more of a blackish tint like his fellow
spiders
in joshua's spider form tang is exposed
to a noxious chemical
from mutated crickets that joshua feeds
them to and causes him to grow even
bigger than a man probably around 8-9
feet tall
as well as enhance his intelligence at
the end of the movie
tang is killed with consuela and the
other spiders in an explosion
in the mall number 7 mother long legs
also known as arachnida acidosasa
they are a giant arachnid kaiju species
that first appeared in the 2017 film
kong skull island the mother long legs
name is based on the famous term daddy
longlegs
a common nickname for various types of
insects and arachnids
the mother long legs design may have
been inspired from the pit spider from
the original king kong from 1933
mother long legs are gigantic
spider-like creatures that stand around
five to seven meters
or between 15 to 23 feet tall they
possess incredibly long legs that
resemble bamboo stalks
allowing them to blend in seamlessly
with the surrounding forest
and with their legs posing as plants
their upper bodies held high above the
canopy
number 6 the quickner they are giant
white eye spiders that appeared in the
mandalorian season 2
which were similar in shape and size
although a little bit more refined based
on the quickner
that first appeared in star wars rebels
season 2.
quickners are predatory non-sentient
spider-like creatures
native to athelon they live in colonies
and hunted any animals that looked to be
a suitable meal
and they used their beaks silk threads
and numbers to attack their prey
their skin was highly resistant to
blaster balls including fire from
starship cannons
however their eyes were vulnerable and
they were also vulnerable to lightsabers
and grenades
in the mandalorian however they were a
swamp species led by a giant queen
that was between 20 to 30 feet tall but
weaker against blaster fires number five
scorpios
scorpios were large primeval arachnids
that first featured in the first
1981 clash of the titans movie these
giant scorpions which closely resembled
the prehistoric scorpion's
puma no scorpius were large around 12
feet long
they hunted in packs and hunted and
killed their prey with their pincers and
venomous stingers
in the 2010 remake however we see bigger
type of scorpions
over twice the size of a human man and
the biggest over 60 feet long
and much faster in the 1981 film
perseus along with his men fought
against three scorpions
that attacked them while they were
asleep in a 2010 remake however they
fight a total of six
bigger and better ones that were
surprisingly obedient to the jinns
commands
number 4 big ass spider the spider is
the titular main antagonist of the 2013
comedy horror film big ass spider
once a small regular arachnid it became
a feral monster when it was infused with
alien dna
seeking to destroy los angeles and make
the city its new territory
the big ass spider is an enormous
blackish grey spider with eight thin
legs
and an engorged abdomen that has
numerous seams lined with hairs
after scientists attempted to use
extraterrestrial dna as an
experimental growth hormone a spider
hidden amongst the test fruits were
exposed
causing it to steadily grow into
gigantic proportions
around 80-100 feet tall in the final
scenes of the movie
it was only killed when a rocket was
launched into its spinneret
and exploding it from its side number 3
angolian this entry has never been seen
in the big screen but has been mentioned
in the law of the rings movies
angolian was a primordial being taking
the shape of a gigantic spider
she was initially an ally of melkor in
amman and for a short time in middle
earth as well
she was a distant mother of shelob and
the oldest and first giant spider of
arda
the true origin of angolian is unknown
and was not even known by the valar
which were gods in this universe
it is said that she came from the
darkness itself and that lay about
arthur and was once an ally of melkor
when he looked down upon the world with
envy
so her size was unconfirmed but stated
to be gigantic
and for that let's put her at number
three number two plasma bugs
on the second spot comes the plasma box
seen in the movie franchise starship
troopers which are massive arachnids
which have the ability to launch equally
massive plasma bursts with
such force that they can fly far beyond
the orbit of planets they are launched
from
which can then deflect asteroids or
slice a starship in two
they serve as not only ground artillery
and air defense roles but also the
planetary defense
cars for the big bug colonies despite
their inherently obscene level of
firepower
their role for offensive actions is
mainly limited to fire support
and long-range bombardment due to their
huge size they are over 20 meters or 65
feet tall
and 30 meters or a hundred feet long and
number one
qmonga the biggest on this list of giant
arachnids
is a giant spider kaiju who first
appeared in the 1967 touhou godzilla
film
the son of godzilla so awakened by a
stray boulder kicked into his valley by
manila the offspring of godzilla
the kumonga began threatening a team of
humans stranded on the island
and eventually captured both manila and
another kaiju called the kamakura
kumonga was later killed by a combined
might of manila and godzilla
kimono is a gigantic spider with a
mostly
black body covered in gold stripes
humongous body
has some tufts of black hair on most
prominently on its legs
humongous was also seen in other movies
like destroy all monsters and final wars
and this arachnid was 60 meters or 197
feet tall
and with this we come to the end of the
video so do like share and subscribe to
our channel and if you already have then
smash that notification bell
as well to get regular updates on our
future videos
that we will be publishing take care fam